tall southpaw daniel lynch for the
royals that's right now the astros with
all those great numbers they do hit
lefties well too but they've never seen
this young man before and he's got what
it takes to shut them down and going
after the first pitch again is altuve
right there is merrifield for it
and altuve went after the first pitch
last night and doubled this time
wit was playing him perfectly to the
right side santana for the second out
to the right side merrifield gobbles it
up he knows he's got a hurry and he gets
correa and how about that first inning
for daniel lynch this will be frohmer's
15th start he's had eight quality starts
of those 15
3.09 era which is very interesting to
see right next to that whip at almost
1.5 is chilling at 1.3
2-0 pitch into center field and for the
first time berryfield is retired by from
valdez
and he hits that one down the line that
looks like two
mccormick chasing it down
santana better hustle and he dives in
safely with a double
there we go didn't hit that one as perez
looks out at fromber and says wow
breaking ball is usually my specialty
but not against you yeah tip of the cap
from salvador perez just foul tipped the
previous one he came back with a better
one in that same spot got the swing and
miss
curveball for a strikeout back-to-back
strikeouts getting salvador perez and
andrew benintendi one hit one man left
on we are scoreless after one up comes
julie
burial ground ball santana touches first
they've got a run down
get him going
and santana tags him out so they are
able to get that double play
here's chaz mccormick
mccormick drives one to center field
michael a taylor back still going back
it is bouncing off the wall chas
mccormick in the second base with a
double
and mccormick now with a five-game
hitting streak a two-out base runner
got those arms extended went to the
deepest part of the ballpark you can see
that he barreled it up leaned back on it
and shot it to center at 103.9 miles an
hour over the head of michael taylor
taylor jones getting the start at d.h
and a swing and a miss he tried to check
his swing could not
lynch works around the lead-off walk
thanks to the double play and then he
works around the double
in the top of the third inning 891 for
the astros beginning with center fielder
jake myers
that ball hit hard into right center
field that's going to be down into the
wall jake myers on his horse he's
heading to second he'll be there with a
stand-up double to start the third
inning
missed the zone here on a 3-2 pitch
putting runners on first and second with
nobody out in the top of the order to up
a little chopper slowly hit towards
third only one play that'll be the first
both runners move up as altuve chops one
to rivera for the first out of the
inning bradley chases it and strikes out
big out for daniel lynch here in the
third oh there it is
so carlos correa will bat with two outs
and two runners in scoring position
there's the ball into center field base
hit off the bat of correa into score
myers maldonado heading home he will be
out at home plate
perez makes the tag michael a taylor
with his eighth assist of the season
so the astros get one but maldonado is
out 8-2
and that's all that houston gets in the
top of the third inning houston leads
one nothing
ben attended the batter he struck out
his last time up
and that ball is just by correa's reach
a base hit for ben attendee so he now
has four hits in his last three games
yeah that's how you hit a curve osher
had a single lead off the second inning
his last time up
gets him on the breaking ball he got
back in the count with a couple of
well-placed fastballs then it gets him
with the hook five strikeouts for
fraumber so ben attendees at first with
two down and now taylor 3-2 pitch
there you go hit to left that will get
down ben and tennie coming around he
will score the tying run and michael a
taylor coming through for the second
time tonight all right this is how you
hit a curveball right here okay see him
up look where this comes up it's eye
level and it's gonna be right there in
the middle it's a hanger and he got out
in front of it and didn't
barrel and he hit it off the end of the
bat which was good it gave ben attendee
plenty of time to score from first base
really a good swing by michael a taylor
it's his 10th double on the season 1-1
game astros and royals top of the six
jose altuve hits the first pitch in the
air to left and to his right waiting on
it now has been attendee and he makes
the catch altuve retired on one pitch
for the first out of the top of the six
michael a taylor
two out
yeah he's doing a nice job too of
pitching to contact tonight letting his
fielders do their work
two-third rivera
lynch six outstanding innings only eight
pitches thrown in the sixth go ahead
young man
now valdez will face the guy who got it
last time ben attendee
there you go chopper and no one to cover
valdez forgot this time no and ben and
he gets his second hit
ben and tandy going to second perfect
throw by maldonado and ben and tendee is
out wait a second it hit dozier
the umpire said it hit dozier a bit so
ben attendee gets second dozier goes to
first and the royals have something
cooking here in the sixth
off the middle
correa cuts it off
throws
got him
very nice play
better believe it a guy that can run
he didn't mess with dozier at second
base he says i can get him in first look
at him showing that range right there
you know how he stays on top of his
throwing swing that's a beautiful play
ben attendee goes to third dozier's at
second and now it's hanser alberto who
has flied out to center field twice
down the line
and comes ben tendy and comes dozier and
the royals go in front three to one on
the hanzer hit
he
to
valdes
gave him something a little too good it
was a hanging curve ball we can tell you
how he likes his swing that's way too
good a pitch he wanted to put that in
the dirt
and the royals get him you could feel it
you could see it coming you can see he
didn't cover first base he was winded
you know you could tell his rhythm was
off and the royals capitalized with a
big hit by alberto there
lynch back for his seventh against a
really good offense he's held them to
only one run
and then he gets him to swing and miss
on a beautiful slider now you see it you
don't and i mean those pitches that are
down in the bottom part of the strike
zone to a back leg of a righty are ideal
he missed that by five inches
swung on and missed on a change up down
and away five strikeouts in the game he
starts the inning and ends the inning
with a strikeout so daniel lynch goes
seven and he gives up one run
jake brents comes out of the bullpen
trying to close this game out and he
will have a tough assignment facing
brantley correa and diaz
brent's
gives him a long fly ball but taylor
right there to run it down one big out
just keep it down it's a slider it is
and struck him out
[Applause]
oh man
he really bear down on diaz
he struck him out
jake brents with his second major league
save the royals looking good taking the
first two out of four here